how is Tyga's like mentality after like
winning second like what so he won
second he was like um I want to do it
again next time we get gold that's
amazing to get gold I was like you know
you have to actually practice right and
he's like yeah yeah I will and then
literally on Monday
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where we are definitely not off the
Record but more importantly yeah we're
really on the record we're really on the
record we're showing the record yo it is
I don't know what this is probably gonna
be uploaded here for now but this is
right now the end of March it is the end
of quarter one of 2023 and we said that
we would check in with each other a
little bit more uh often nowadays so
just wanted to do a quick check-in with
everybody how are you all doing it yeah
it was a quarterly check-in yeah
quarterly check-in how's everybody doing
why are you laughing I saw you I saw you
were the bit nah oh yeah you were in
Vietnam how was it Vietnam I was in
Taiwan I was in Vietnam I've been gone
I've been missing all of you very very
much most of you most everybody busy
what did you do what did you do in those
two places any chance you got food
poisoning
I thought you guys hate each other
we do stop with the spoilers all right
John wait so what happened with Taiwan
and Vietnam I was out there I was
teaching you know it's been actually
um a really really long time since a lot
of countries and events have been thrown
like dance conventions and camps and
stuff like that because of like covid
that like they're finally starting to
like roll back into momentum like even
in uh January Vibe like the dance
competition was the first time in three
years it came back even today uh here
you know the the news that today is
technically the end of The Declaration
of the covet did you know that in L.A
today well they just passed something
like Congress just formally ended it
right the Senate did yeah it was like
like the pandemic is now over the state
of emergency or whatever the [__] it was
like the [__] been Oliver [__]
I'm just glad the government said
something okay I'm just glad that we
have a definite ending I was on Twitter
the other day and hashtag covet is still
a thing
[Laughter]
I see the little Trends on the side it's
like Cove it's still it's still real
everybody still be worried about it yeah
well I mean so yeah Dad's stuff has been
down things are finally coming back
which means that you know I'll probably
be like actually doing more real work
and like not being here around anymore
because this has always been just a
fallback Whoa man what the [__] dude
because his real job is teaching
children the trick is to get off a
sinking ship yeah this is that's the
trick you can't stay on no that's like
it's a launch pad
um but no those events have been popping
back up so it's been built to finally go
back out there I did get some food
poisoning in Vietnam and it wasn't the
street food it was actually like
probably The Catch of the Day which was
actually a nice fish from a nice
restaurant but that was the only meal
that I had by myself so that was the
only one that I can how did you know it
was that was it like within hours or
like you were like so I think it was
like six or seven hours later I was
judging the competition of the event
that day right and I'm judging I'm
judging fine and I and then I have a
judge showcase at the end of the
competition I do my showcase and right
after I finish my showcase I go up to
the side of the stage suddenly the upper
area of my stomach starts burning and I
like it just keeps getting so intense I
end up Keeling over I'm like literally
sitting on the floor I'm starting to
sweat more than what I was performing
wow right and I still got to go back on
stage to hand like the the winners
prizes and the giant checks and like
trophies and random [__] like that but
I'm literally like [__] sweat you
know when you have like uncontrollable
yeah [__] yeah yeah so then after that I
didn't even go out to the the after
party I went straight back to my room
and that's when I started throwing up
threw up like maybe I got everything
Vietnamese bacteria dude like three
hours at night and then for the next
like two three days I was just pissing
out my ass oh barely eating eating super
asking for a super bland food you know
what I mean and trying to drink just
like I needed some Vietnamese hey you
cut weight though that's nice I did I
did cut weight
it's a good weight loss program though
it is it's actually really good it
happens all the time when traveling huh
yeah a lot of people get it hey but your
gut is now that much stronger now now
you're either that or my [__] is that
much more burnt I really don't know your
asshole's stronger too that's temporary
yeah that's good but right after my food
poisoning like I once I came out of my
you know little hermit shell of like
staying in my shitty ass small hotel
room for like days on end you got a
shitty hotel room you wanna shout them
out
it's just one of those things where it's
like the buildings are so squished next
to each other all right that when you
look out your window you just see the
wall of the other building so it just
feels like a prison kind of can you
touch it almost I have to close the
blinds if I want to shower because I
could definitely see into the other
rooms and vice versa can you hear them
no I can't you should have tried to
throw up into the other room
that is very mature I'm on the window
did any of you guys did any of you guys
see uh his actual Workshop no it's
really good I saw I saw a little girl
[__] crushing it she was like doing
some [__] Matrix [__] and I was like
what the [__] yeah so that girl's name
is Mio
um I believe she's from Indonesia she's
nine years old she's not only smashing
in my class but she was also entering
the kids battle because there's jams uh
that are happening during that same
event on on my channel alone I posted on
Tick Tock it's got like over 11 million
views in a couple days wow but I don't
even really do Tick Tock I just happen
to throw this clip up I had like 40 000
followers like a week ago like 350. holy
nice and I don't even like do take time
350 000 so you're getting 300 000
followers in a week yeah but they
thought you were a nine-year-old girl
[Laughter]
but that's not even the crazy part her
freestyle Clips on like stance elements
and on like the RF Jam like Tick Tock
those have 40 million views each
she's like starting to get like
interviewed and stuff like that by like
different like because she's crazy good
she's amazing she's amazing it's just
like that young Swagger that ruthless
Relentless child like like fearlessness
yeah like willing to go places people
might be scared to go but she's like
[__] and it's just so deep and mature
for such a small but and everybody wants
to see like a little girl destroy the
world you know what I mean but her
movements are sharp and they're very
adult yeah amazing like kids can't
[__] be like
that's how your processor go off no it's
like you know the Wall Street
that little girl stand in front of me
like yeah what the [__] like look like
she's about to get run over by the way
but no it's just it's amazing to like
see the dance Community like just like
thriving and just blowing up again after
like such a period of being like the
lowest tier of in you know industry that
could bounce can you feel that energy
you can feel like when you're going
through this these places you can feel
like uh the dance can be going like [__]
yeah we're finally back the hunger is
like real and also especially because
like that event used to be in Singapore
now it moved to Vietnam basically
because Singapore's inflation went crazy
it's cheaper to do it too expensive yeah
way cheaper to do in Vietnam people are
just actually hungrier literally yeah
that makes sense yeah hunger probably
would have been less food poisoning in
the Singapore that's true there's more
regulations there Anthony was being
literal he's like the Huggers [__] me
everybody showing up you can see the rib
cages uh no but it is it is amazing just
to see like people that have like just
been seemingly dormant but like they've
just been working on their craft
probably in their [__] living rooms
and stuff coming back out trying to like
eat up competitions like roast classes
like everything like that so does that
inspire you to want to battle again or
something I actually never really gotten
into battling not like Ryan or anything
like that who was amazing by the way I
haven't done it in a long long time but
uh I was always I'm very inspired in
general back in like the dancing so it
is a really really so you're gonna leave
us though you're gonna leave jk just
every now and then can we tell this
video why Anthony is leaving Victor yeah
it'll be great for viewers I am not
going to be here in a couple weeks
because of Coachella I already told you
guys oh cool but I know somebody misread
the text from time to time you did that
last year right yeah I did was that your
first no oh no because I was like it was
fifth that was my second last year when
you guys are all in the match do you
know who each other is
laughs
that's like a so we're all wearing these
masks like how can you tell like I know
it's like a BlizzCon question like sorry
I swear to God it's Mike song is there
ever confused
that's why they have the wild hair
I gotta really memorize each other's
eyebrows
um but yes uh to answer your question
it's very confusing
but that's the that's the whole point
yeah so Coachella just to answer your
question uh Coachella this year I'm sure
this video comes out after Michelle I
hope
um but yeah we're performing for uh
Jackson he's coming back this year not
under 88 Rising but doing his own set oh
dope yeah so that's that's an incredible
thing for him I know we're I know where
he's not gonna be
not on JK news
for sure you knew
conflicts guys scheduling conflicts
thank you officially that's like a Byron
Allen connector that was really good so
you heard about this like he's not
coming to JK news thing
what's going on with that
I heard he would like to but he's busy
he was okay look he was really sorry
guys like the context of course we were
trying to get him on to the show uh the
of course like scheduling conflicts I
never knew I was in charge of scheduling
scheduling conflict Dex is like it's not
me it's my peoples that's my
videographer he does my schedule
thanks you formally for like trying to
work around his schedule and stuff like
that he's been very very I feel like any
celebrity at that level comes to JK news
and then they waste their career for no
reason yeah they're wasting time yeah
they're gonna come here and they're
gonna throw their career down to drink
Brendan Frazier took 15 years to come
back after coming on JK
yeah this guy to win a [__] Academy
Award to get some love again he had to
dig deep dude he had to go away for a
while yeah he did No More Encino Man
stuff remember Hugh Grant's still
recovering I know what's the last movie
you see that guy
JK news effect we're like a downtown Las
Vegas crack cooker you know oh yeah
we'll suck you dry it's the just the
responses if there's experience there
hey when you go to Vietnam do you get to
see any family or anything
uh that's what my mom be always asking
all the time I told her for sure she's
the husband I was I visited all your
family she's like really no
crazy
no
wow my dad's laughing in the background
but I love toying with her deep rooted
emotions
just like a whim dude we went to it and
we went to a Beachside City uh called
Danang which is where the event was out
oh I love the nag dude most of my family
is like spread out in like a lot of
rural parts and then also places like
Saigon and whatnot so take you hours to
see everybody like hours and hours and
hours more than that yeah because I'll
be happy Google translate myself what'd
you say I was talking to some Vietnamese
kids and they were like oh your accent
is like so it's such a like a South
Vietnamese accent I was like yeah that's
why we live in America we lost the war
didn't even know the history they're
like oh yeah
but you know that's how it is sometimes
it's fun back to our check and how are
you guys doing like how how's everybody
else doing I think we're running out of
time dude
we'll use the rest of the time for Nick
we didn't we didn't see you for a minute
so we we were it was nice it is kind of
weird to like not see you and have
everybody all together today it's kind
of weird I don't like the energy
actually yeah no it was better before we
skip we skipped part two oh oh like
tomorrow was gone too yeah he decided to
go spend family time you think we're
gonna go on it
definitely sorry guys I got
fed time
to put on this cooler no funniest thing
about bart is he's apologizes for dude
for that he's like hey guys I know I
gotta do a little [__] move and hang
out with my family
sorry for hanging with the boys yeah
he's like I know I'm a little [__]
right now but I got to do this stuff for
the for the albums and stuff I know it's
very West Hollywood of me but
that's Holly very West Hollywood of me
but I'm gonna have to spend time with my
family because they love me I did just
see take this competition dude that was
[__] crazy that's so cool that was
crazy how'd he do uh he got second place
that was like that was really cool
because like you you see like this kid
get born and you kind of you spend a lot
of days with them and then you're like
okay I kind of know who he is but then
like you know people's internal thoughts
you really don't know
who people really are until they're
pushed right so like I see taika as Jiu
Jitsu practice literally every single
day he's the [__] around kid he's the
guy that's like doing snow angels
staring at the ceiling technique never
really practicing or taking anything
seriously you know and then so
um we see a bunch around the kids like
sign up for jiu jitsu competitions and
when he was four he was too young when
he was five we're like oh maybe we
should sign him up so we talked to his
coach or like hey coach like what do you
think about us signing tyke up he goes
with someone like taika he's like
there's two routes he goes one he gets
his ass beat so [__] hard he doesn't
want to do Jiu Jitsu ever again
because we don't want that thanks he
goes two uh because he's like these kids
some of these kids they come in [__]
ready you know and he goes and he goes
there's this other kid he's like the
other one is they light a fire under his
ass and he understands what it means to
actually train now he goes I personally
think maybe it might be good to just
test it so we're like oh [__] all right
so we we do all of it so the month
leading up to this Jujitsu competition
he takes the regular class
and he takes the competition class and
the competition class is [__] serious
there's almost like no lessons usually
like a regular Jiu-Jitsu class is like
talking practice talking practice you
know in your life the teacher's like
teaching you and whatever the
competition class it's like drilling
it's like watching like little baby UFC
fighters they're just drilling for an
hour and they come out [__] drenched
so he took that whole class and even in
that class he's [__] around and then
we had a big powwow the day before the
competition
uh the coaches like like you see all the
kids like [__] drenched and like like
these little Warriors and [__] and then
the coach was like um okay who here is
nervous and then you have like five kids
going oh I'm nervous I'm nervous he goes
good I want you to use it tomorrow it's
it's it you might feel weird but you can
use it to be better and Tiger's like I'm
not nervous and then so I was like this
[__] you don't even know where
you're signing up for next day you
signed up for him but yeah yeah the next
day I'm driving to the competition this
[__] sitting next time and he
looks at me I'm so [__] nervous
you told me you were not nervous
yesterday
doesn't even exist in kids I know so
like I'm so [__] nervous
[Laughter]
I had no idea how I was gonna break it
out dad I had no idea I thought it was
gonna be like I was prepared for when
they called his name he goes on the mat
and he pisses on the map that's what I
was prepared for I don't know what
well I just don't know because it's like
he's such a [__] wild card I don't
know what's gonna happen you know like
in practice he's tickling other kids and
doing all kinds of shits his skill set
dude yeah I know and then but then or
foreshadowing but you see the the rest
go like this are you ready are you ready
in the
boom I just [__] see this side of
taika that I've never seen before he
just like Snapped into [__]
competition mode and then the game plan
that we've been rehearsing for the whole
month which is like Snap Downs take the
back that's all he was doing he was like
being [__] aggressive with it and you
see all the parents
stand up and cheer from our school wow
because they all know him as the [__]
around kid you know what I mean it's
like everyone knows him as oh that's
taika he's like the cute little [__]
around kid that's always tickling people
and messing around and like like little
he gets big kids in trouble because even
big kids are trying to like practice and
he's like
he's like that and then so to see that
guy like bringing it on and like all the
parents like
yeah having watched the video it's like
watching baby Yoda fight
but I see it was really cool it was
really cool but that's also it's kind of
like you're watching like how did they
pull this off like I don't know how they
shot that I don't know
oh that's crazy but it was cool to see
like a complete different side of him
that as a dad who you think you know
your son would have never have seen
unless you put him in that position
because you're thinking Titan's gonna
start tickling this kid yeah I don't
know is he gonna get all of a sudden
like after 30 days he's scared all of a
sudden like who knows what's gonna
happen so she got a second place out of
uh how many kids two
kids yeah it's him first another kid so
he's the second place I think it was
like three or four you did like maybe
like three or four matches that day
because he had a couple of Yogi and a
couple of ghee matches oh wow
some thoughts some notes as an observer
okay
I think that you feed him too well the
other kid was [__] hungry dude like
like his parents don't feed him unless
he wins
like that kid what he's on top attack
I'm like this kid doesn't give a [__]
this kid needs to eat food later he's
like a gladiator like a child Gladiator
he's like a raised Warrior from like the
[__] Reeds from like a swamp or some
[__] he needs a Vietnamese vacation yeah
some of these kids are crazy man I saw
this one kid he won like the uh so he
could wear medals which is like your
weight division your skill level
whatever and then you have like almost
kind of like the best Grappler of the
day and you get like the belt right and
then you get like a sword or something a
sword yeah so this kid is one the whole
[__] this [__] looked like Mr T
and so one of the other presidents go
talk to the dad and I was like oh like
how do you how often do you guys train
or whatever he goes oh we traveled the
world training so they train at all the
best gyms all the best schools so like
Asian tiger parents for jujitsu for jiu
jitsu but worldwide so this kid gets a
sword he's like yeah I put up with the
other swords honestly yeah he's like
yeah we're like hey you want this he's
not even as big as my life for you I'm
like dude this is [__] crazy it feels
like Musashi going to all these
different [__] schools challenging
every every goddamn School how is Tyga's
like mentality after like winning second
like what so he won second he was like
um I want to do it again next time I get
gold that's amazing to get gold I was
like you know you have to actually
practice right and he's like yeah yeah I
will and then literally on Monday
[Laughter]
oh this [__] is